ready
[Laughter]
hey look at that violence work we
shouldn't use violence we could be
there
[ __ ] is this sad or is it funny i can't
really tell like what is
it odin what are you doing
why are you standing in the kitty bed
you're too big all day because
the kitty is in your bed
get on oh then
[Laughter]
oh so cute
i feel like it doesn't count if it's an
all cute that was not a life so far i
have laughed how many times
i've oh yeah let's see the ladies ignore
this hey man looking good oh thanks
what's your routine bro how much you
lived
oh that's funny because it's so true
it doesn't count if it's haha funny
because it's true then it doesn't count
so far how many strikes i've if i get
three strikes i'm out
cool we're still in it holy moly
god damn
all right i'm just that's just respect
that's not life
wait this cat has a collar footage yeah
we can see the whiskers
what's what's about the sausages
you've dropped
that's that's legit oh that's
[ __ ] funny
oh i hope i get reincarnated a cat
that's so [ __ ] funny
oh that was great i'd take a strike for
that one say
that's just cute that's as cute that
doesn't count
if it's cute i
oh
[Music]
this is cute
i am terrible at this that guy's no
strike it was cute
i told the others i told you the rules
it's only fair
[Laughter]
that's so cute suspect returns to the
scene of the crime
he put himself in jail afterwards he
pleaded guilty at an instant
see yeah he's okay great
come on we've all done that get out of
here
well if i wanted to kill myself i'd
climb up your ego level and jump down to
your iq level and
kill myself is that did you write that i
mean
is that from something
comeback in real life yeah right it
doesn't work
like that y'all think you're so slick
then
new headset with physical pain
simulation
oh it's the plank isn't it
perfectly cut dude oh my god
that was painful watching that i didn't
life
[Applause]
jesus christ well played
all right i'm willing to give tech talks
a try
let's see that turned water into wine
can't turn your [ __ ] into mine
yes sir yes sir
where's the funny what are you okay what
are you doing
oh never mind what are we doing there's
what why why don't this is smaller than
last time this is
you messed up last time remember
nah oh my stuff has sent me a really
funny video
let's see this is literally edgar say
good boy
say good dog come on masters
[ __ ] you egg guy you're not a good boy
tick tock tick tocks aren't funny
[Music]
okay that was [ __ ] great
it's funny because i would definitely do
the same too
okay fine that one i had
what
oh my god dude i'm sipping through these
and they're so unfunny there's so many
fun
oh god
these are the compilations um
[Music]
okay that's that was close i'll give you
that
oh there's not enough milk and i just
mixed everything i have to go to the
shop now uh
the milk the milk is finished hey i
cannot accept cats
i cannot i'm almost done i cannot accept
it no see the milk
see milk have a lasting milk come on i'm
not miss my person
that was it what was the joke
what did i miss it
night glasses night glasses nice glasses
okay fire hell yeah hell yeah okay
fine where's my charger did you look on
the bedside
table yeah look it should be there
it's not there what about the other one
no it's not there either
sophia i swear if it's there and i came
upstairs for nothing
what's that literally me and marzia
seriously oh i fell for the relatable
name
god damn it ah
oh that's so cute
making my way downtown walking fast oh
[ __ ] it's
jacksepticeye what the [ __ ]
making my way downtown walking fast i'm
a seagull go [ __ ] yourself
they're so confusing what the [ __ ] was
that jack
why did you hurt the seagull jack
no
is that real no that's not real are you
[ __ ] kidding
this is a real clip
whoa uh it gets up
takes a while obviously very shook
that can't be real that can't be real
that's fake
that's still funny if it was really
horrible so the fact that it's fakes
makes it funny
bro y'all girls on this app be capping
too damn much like
y'all be claiming y'all wanna all right
i made it your life you lose
how many strikes did i get say zero
amazing subscribe for more subscribers
to me
and that's it see you guys